No, no, no, no, no, no. Okay, load, load
NASDAQ. Load NASDAQ. The put this here.
Okay. Log in, log in, log in. Okay, it's
time to make some mother money. Let's
go. Okay, I'm going to short NASDAQ.
4,000 shares. Hold on. Hold on. Okay.
And sell, sell, sell, sell, sell. Boom.
That's how we make money. Easy day
trading life. Yeah, we all kind of wish
day trading was actually like that, but
it is nothing like that at all.
Definitely my desk does not look like
this when I'm actively trading. So the
first thing I do when I come into the
markets every day is I come in before
the market opens. I come in about 15 20
minutes before the market opens. And
this gives me time to prepare. And the
first thing that I do is I open
forexfactory.com and open the calendar.
What this does is it shows you what news
reports there are that day. And so today
is a Wednesday and what we have going on
is it looks like there's news at about
10:00 a.m. There's already news has
already happened before the market. I
don't really care about that. You know,
sometimes it'll cause a spike before the
market, but right now what I'm
interested in is the 10:00 news because
for me that's after 30 minutes after the
market open. Even though I'm coming in
at, you know, 7:30, this is market time.
And so market opens at 9:30 technically
Eastern time. And so basically it means
okay at 10:00 30 minutes after market
opens there is news. And so I have a
actual indicator on my chart that also
tells me when these news cycles are
happening and will draw lines on them.
Otherwise I normally just draw a line.
And so this allows me to go in and say,
"Okay, going into those times, I want to
be paying attention that there's a news
event happening and that I need to be
aware of that that it's going to cause
potential move in the market." And so
what I'm looking at is the NASDAQ
futures and the ES futures or the S&P
500 futures. And the next thing that I
do going into analyzing these markets
and prepping for the market to open is I
pull up a 15-minute chart of both of
them and I look at, okay, where are the
major swings in the market? You know,
what are the big support and resistance
levels doing? What is the major trend
doing? And right now, looking at the
NASDAQ, we've been bouncing between
these two major levels already. I've
already had those drawn. And then today,
you know, we're kind of just we we
gapped down from yesterday and then
overnight it's kind of had a little bit
of movement. But big picture-wise is I'm
seeing, you know, okay, well, we've
bounced here a few times. Maybe we'll
get something there. There's kind of
this downtrend line here, too. Uh
there's not really a ton that's super
interesting right now, right at the
open. Um so, you know, that maybe says
that today is going to be a slow day,
and I need to just be patient. Again,
looking at uh the ES futures, they look
very similar, but there is this kind of
level down here, this kind of double
bottom that the markets had overnight
going into a smaller chart. You can kind
of see that right here is there is a
double bottom here and there is that
pre-market news. That's what this move
is from. And so maybe something
interesting today would be if the market
comes back down here and I can look for
a bounce off of that level. Going into a
one minute chart here, the biggest thing
for my strategy is that 30 minute window
after the market opens. I constantly see
where the market will swing down into a
level during that point. It'll line up
with that timing and then I'll look for
a reversal pattern. And so that's all
I'm doing in the mornings. I'm prepping
and seeing where it's likely to have
those reversals at that timing, seeing
where potential news is happening as
well. So once I'm done with that, I will
go in and, you know, I'll post this to
my chat room kind of telling people what
I'm looking at. But at that point, it's
just a waiting game. It's sitting for
about 30 minutes and waiting for those
opportunities to show up. If they do,
take a trade. And if they don't, don't
take a trade. Okay. So, just to show you
this setup while I'm kind of just
waiting for the market, I have four
monitors. And essentially what I'm
looking at is, you know, I look at the
15-minute of NASDAQ and ES just to help
kind of look at the big picture. And I
look at I have a screen with the 5m
minute of the NASDAQ and then a screen
with the five minute of the ES and then
a screen with the 5m minute of the oil
futures. And the whole idea there is I
am mainly just looking at how it reacts
to these levels on a 1 minute or a 5m
minute. and I'm just patiently waiting
for it to be in a good spot. That makes
sense. You don't want to be reactive to
the market, you know, even though it
looks like it's kind of going up or down
and there's potential moves. The way I
found to be consistently profitable over
time is sitting patiently waiting for it
to come to, you know, your setup. I want
the market to come down here to this
level. And right now, it's not really
doing that. And if it doesn't do that,
then I won't find a trade today. Oil
right now, I think, is more interesting
in terms of it's kind of had a a failed
breakout attempt here of this big
downtrend line that was off of a larger
15-minute chart. That's this big
downtrend line right here. My thought
is, hey, maybe we, you know, see some
failure here. And there's this big move
up right here that I see as a weakness
in the market. if it decides to get
moving here, there's no real support
until really kind of this high or or
down here. And so, if I can get in on
this move right here, that's it looks
like it's close to happening, that's
where I'm going to be able to get in
short and catch a potential big swing
down. And what I'm basically waiting for
here is I want to see this close with a
lower high in the market. It's getting
pretty close to potentially doing that,
but I need to see a bearish candlestick
form here because that's going to give
me the confidence that, okay, it's
setting in a double top here and a lower
high that we have, you know, that it's
playing out to what I want to see. And
if it doesn't do that, I'm just going
to, you know, sit on my hands and knees
and wait for a better opportunity, if
that's later today or tomorrow. We've
had that 30 minutes now. It's now bottom
of the hour at that 8:00 time. We've had
we have a downtrend here. All I'm
looking for now is this downtrend to
basically break. I want to see it break
this downtrend and make one more attempt
to go lower. Basically make a double
bottom here and then I like that as a
signal to go higher. Essentially the
idea is that hey we've come down to this
you know more major level here looking
at a 5minute now where you know it's had
that double bottom there before and so I
think that it's likely with this timing
of being 30 minutes after the market
open which is 8:00 my time 10:00 Eastern
time and that we will you know
potentially reverse this move but you
know you need to see a couple things
before it happens because sometimes the
market can will continue its downtrend
lower or it'll just not work out. You
know, it'll break up a little bit, but
that'll be kind of a bull trap actually
and then keep going lower. And that's
why I don't like getting in on this
initial move. So, that's why sometimes
I'll even more elect to look at a
5-minute chart because a 5-minute chart
won't be as fast-paced. It's not as
likely to bait you in to a trade that
you shouldn't be in. you know, seeing
that the market will go up here on a
fivem minute, come back, and then if it
produces another strong bullish candle
on a five-minute, that's a really strong
confirmation. You know, just looking at
over here, over here, this is on a
five-minute chart, and it's a really
clean double bottom where it comes in
here and you have multiple candlesticks
showing up that then launch this market
higher. And so, the only reason to
really get in on a one minute is if you
have FOMO and you're scared about
missing out on the move. And I've
realized over time that it's kind of
better to enter in on a slower chart
because that noise will be taken out and
it's not as intense emotionally. So, I'm
just going to really just sit here and
watch and see if it pulls back for me.
If it if it doesn't and it just shoots
up here, that's okay. I that's not a
move I want. It's not about capturing
all the moves. It's about trading the
moves that you can be profitable in.
That's the biggest key when it comes to
trading. So many people lose money
consistently because they're trying to
react to the market and capture every
move that they think they should get.
You can't be profitable doing that. It's
all about waiting and getting the moves
that you can be profitable with. Okay,
so it's actually been a little while
now. It's past that 8:00 time. We had a
little bit of a bounce here if you look
at a one minute chart, but I'm looking
here at a 5m minute and I actually want
to get in long on this right here if it
breaks up a little bit more. You can see
it kind of had a fake out here, but I'm
going to get in long here above that
little break for nine contracts because
I see this as a double bottom.
Essentially, we've come down here,
bottomed. Hold on, just got filled. Let
me just move I'm going to move my stop
down below this low and then it's made a
push up showing some strength and has
come back down and made a higher low.
So, it's starting to show, okay, we're
in a potential uptrend. Um, and then so
I just, you know, I saw that little
punch higher and then it pulled back and
then I wanted to get in on a break of
that. Um, go to go into a one minute
chart to kind of just show you that it
it's just a a little bit more
confirmation for me. But overall, that's
the pattern that I'm looking for is, you
know, we've come down to that level. We
found a bottom at that timing after that
news. And then from here, what I want to
do is because the market found some
resistance up here, I want to if we get
up there, obviously, um I want to take
off. I have nine contracts here. I'm
going to take off I think 2/3. This
market's kind of choppy, so I'm
literally just going to put a sell limit
here at 2/3. Um you know, my risk right
now is about
$730 for these. And so I'm going to take
off 2/3 of my trade at that. You know,
the idea is, okay, big picture-wise,
looking at the NASDAQ here on a
15-minute chart is, you know, I'm buying
this bottom here. We this could be a
bigger push higher. Now, I I think it's
kind of unlikely. You know, we're kind
of in a bigger downtrend potentially. We
have this downtrend line. And so, that's
why I want to kind of take off some of
my trade just right here and see if if I
can just get kind of that move. Uh, and
then the rest I I'll trail up to break
even. Um, or, you know, asset kind of
goes higher. And if it slows down, you
know, I'll manage based on that. Um, I
just give an update on oil. Oil is kind
of not really doing much either. News is
about to come out in 7 minutes. Unlikely
I'm going to find a good trade during
that just because it's pretty volatile,
but potentially something could set up.
So, at this point, it's just kind of
twiddling my thumbs and waiting for this
to play out. Now, interesting thing to
show you while this is kind of working
in my favor is here's the NASDAQ on a
one minute chart. You can see where I
entered in and how much it's up. And
then here is the ES futures on a one
minute chart. And you can see if I
quickly cycle back between them, the
NASDAQ is way higher than the ES. As I
was going into this trade, I was looking
at kind of this move here, essentially
saying, okay, how which one looks more
bullish? And you can see that that move,
the NASDAQ here was stronger and the
pullback wasn't as far down compared to
here. the ES, you can see it made a more
of a double bottom. And so my idea with
that was, hey, I see that this is, you
know, it's stronger and so I want to get
in on the stronger move. And so now that
we're getting moving here, I'm actually
going to manage this more on a one
minute chart. I'm just going to pull up
my riskreward tool here to kind of see
where I'm at. I'm going to move
everything up to break even at this
point because if the market comes all
the way down here, I pretty much want to
be out of the trade. It's going to spike
up here and come back down. There's no
point in risking, you know, giving all
that back up, right? And taking a loss.
I'd rather give the profits back up and
be break even on the day at least. It
would suck, but it's totally possible.
This market is pretty whipssawy. I think
if it got up a tiny bit more like up
here, I would have started to move my
trailing stop-loss up. But big
picture-wise, again, I want to manage
this on a 5m minute. And so, I want to
try and give it some wiggle room, right?
I think the big picture in play here is
that it it could continue to move higher
off of this double bottom. Now, it
totally could. There could be some kind
of downtrend here that it's hitting. Um,
and you know, that's just a part of
trading. Sometimes your your trades work
out really well and sometimes they
don't. And because I was risking kind of
this much, I want to be going for two
times my risk at a minimum. I don't
think it's worth it getting into a trade
and trying to overmanage it and not
getting as much money as you could have
because at the end of the day, you know,
trading is all about math and you have
to be getting the right amount of
profits for how much you're you're
taking because, you know, these only
work out, let's say 50% of the time I
need to be making a good amount of money
when I'm right. And if you overmanage,
you're going to be, you know,
hamstringing yourself and handicapping
yourself to be consistently profitable.
And so oil here as well is as this is
just playing out. Oil here is a couple
minutes from the news. And so I'm going
to watch that just because big
picture-wise we have had a nice move up.
We've had a big move here and then a big
move here. We could um get a little
overextended and move up to here to this
level up here and then and then reverse.
And so I'll just keep an eye on that and
potentially get in a trade there if it
makes a nice signal. But so far, it's
pretty quick to move higher. This is
finding some resistance. Part of me is
nervous and wants to move my stop loss
up here. But again, that feels like I'm
getting out really, really early. I want
to give it a little bit more room. See
if it maybe just spikes lower here and
then and then moves up. Again, it's hard
to be disciplined to do that when it's
starting to slow down. It had that
really nice move right away. Sometimes
they work out great. Sometimes, you
know, it slows up here. And so that's a
really nice move that of it eating that
up. You know, part of me really still
wants to move this up and capture some
of those profits, but I don't want to do
it before it breaks it needs to break
this high first for me to feel
comfortable with saying, okay, it's it's
put in a little bottom here. Now, oil is
just came out with the news. It is
starting to, you know, make a double top
here. Um, I don't want to jump in too
early on this candlestick just because
if going into a one minute chart, you
can see it happened pretty quick. Um,
and and that' be mainly because of the
news. I want it to show, you know, a
bigger signal that, hey, it's not just
kind of a a liquidity whip and then it's
going to continue higher. You know, look
at looking at this candlestick right
here. It moved down and then moved up,
right? Like what I want to be waiting
for is it to show honestly probably a
couple candlesticks before it does that.
That's sometimes what I like to do is
almost just go to a blank chart and say,
"Hey, what does this look like?" Because
not having the trade on and all those
drawings kind of sometimes cloud your
judgment and you can just look at it
blank. There is this downtrend right
here that we're working against. Um, but
again, I think if we break that, it's a
good chance to continue higher. Like my
trade is break even. I'm not going to
lose any money on it and the riskreward
potential is still good. I'm liking oil
here as well just to bring this chart up
on the side. I want to be patient here
with getting in on this first
candlestick after the news. This I like
going into a one minute chart. I try to
avoid that sometimes, but in terms of it
has made a double top here and we are at
the highs and so I think I'm actually
going to look for a trade here. But I
think I'm going to go ahead and do half
size. I want to see how this candlestick
closes. And I think see how the next
candle actually moves as well. Um ju
because it's kind of showing, you know,
it's it's been showing strength a lot. I
think it's likely to just continue
higher. And so I don't want to get in a
trade that's not going to be great.
Okay. So now this is kind of why I
didn't want to move my stop up too quick
is because looking at this is this. It
bottomed here and now it's looking to
break this high. And that's where you
can kind of start to see, okay, there's
maybe an uptrend here. You know, it
could just double top here and continue
lower. So, if you've been wondering what
platform I'm using here, this is called
the Ninja Trader. You can start
practicing with live data, which most
places actually cost money for right
away. I'll leave a link for it in the
description of this video, or you can
use this QR code right here. And so as
this is starting to maybe put in a
bottom here, this is still really not
looking great. I almost want to take
half off here at 1x, but it's really
hard to sometimes when it just feels
like it's just not that much money for a
trade. Um, oil here I think is starting
to look better as well. In terms of the
one minute, it's kind of gone up and
started to show some weakness. And on
the five-minute we have this double top
happening. And so I think for this I'm
going to get in just to kind of big this
make this bigger picture here. I'm going
to wait for this candlestick to close
and I'm going to get in short here. I
think actually at my larger size because
this is kind of what I was waiting for.
I'm waiting for that news to happen and
it's shown multiple candlesticks here of
slowing down. And so I'm again I'm just
going to wait here 30 seconds while this
happens. I'm looking at my NASDAQ trade
on the other screen and I think actually
what would make me feel better here with
this NASDAQ trade is potentially taking
a third off here. It I know it's kind of
back and forth here and this is how
trading is sometimes is it's hard to
just sit on your hands and knees and
just patiently wait for it to happen and
it can make you doubt your you know what
to do properly. And so I'm going to put
in my sell stop here. If oil breaks
below this, I'm going to get in short.
You know, it it's farther away from this
uh uptrend, and I think if it hits
there, it's going to break that. And
we'll see if I get filled here in a few
minutes. NASDAQ here again is I think
this looks good in terms of a one minute
chart to overanalyze it. And in terms
of, you know, on on the 5m minute here,
uh I think it looks good, too. I think
hopefully we get kind of a a punch up
here and it can hit this and then I can
trail my the rest of my trade stop
losses and close out with a nice profit.
So, as this punches higher and gets
closer to my takerit, I'm going to
actually trail up my stop loss for this
as well because as it gets closer, I am,
you know, my my risk is my potential
profit gets limited. And so, I don't
want it to come up here, almost hit, and
then sell off all the way down here. I'd
rather just get out here. And so what
I'm going to do is I'm on a one minute
chart here and I'm going to just trail
my stop loss here up via the previous
candlestick high. Essentially, if it
goes up, great. It hit my take-profit
target and I took off 2/3 of my trade at
two times my risk. And so it's pretty
agonizing waiting through this spot
right here. But that's, you know, again,
kind of just a part of trading. My next
thing is thinking, okay, are we going to
continue higher, right? Big picture,
this is a nice move up. We could run
into some potential resistance up here.
And so for this, you know, normally I
would trail up my my stop loss here
pretty quickly, but I want to be
managing this on a 5m minute. And so
five minute is kind of I think I'm going
to pull it up to below this candlestick
here because I think it's either going
to come up here and you know chop for a
while and then continue higher breaking
this downtrend line and this resistance
or it's going to come up here and just
sell off and that's fine. Um also
looking at oil here. It's continuing
higher. I'm just going to get out uh or
not get out but just take off my entry
because it looks like it's just going to
continue higher. So, this looks like
it's about to knock me out here, and
that is totally okay. I am up over
$1,200 for the morning. You know, I've
only been trading for about an hour,
hour and a half. That's about as long as
I normally trade, and I'm totally okay
getting out there. Now, if you want to
learn more about the strategy, I have a
free candlestick strategy cheat sheet
that you can get in the link in the
description below this video or using
this QR code here. And if you want a
more indepth explanation of how this
strategy works instead of this kind of
raw live trading style, check out this
video right here.